I don't need a man like oh I get what I
want I guess I can just say buy my own I
don't need a man you don't have the
youth and you don't have the Purity at
30. it's gone so it's you don't have
what men value a minute the price we we
run Society we keep Society going that's
why one in three men are virgins are
haven't had sex in the past year because
nobody wants them it's not just the
sexiest experience it's the it's that
whole especially when you've had a child
for someone else especially I will say
majority of men Legacy is very important
do not yes there's a lot of baby mamas
around okay okay hold on hold on and
then this Falls in with the age thing as
well because as we're saying the old
you're getting the more Barren you're
becoming so then because you're older
you should accept that a man will cheat
on you is that is that what we're saying
you could dial on too so yeah but we've
done it that's the point guys like not
every woman need a man like it does it
want to step out step out like when we
are fatty that's my value when you say
oh you know 20 anymore so you don't have
any evaluate no I actually my value is
that I can stand by my own I can pay my
bills I'm independent and this is
because I'm party because when I was 20
I was probably looking for a man to you
know help me out in you know just to in
order to are you gonna be happy 60
without a family by yourself yeah
because in in the world I can do a lot
of things I can I can if I cannot have
my own baby I can adopt it I can have a
pet I can do whatever else I'm not just
a bloody baby
I'm not a baby machine so my value
doesn't depend from how many eggs
children though I don't know I still
don't I never found a man that let me
think okay let's have a baby still so if
I don't know I don't I don't want to
have a child I don't think my life gonna
be
saddle with the right man
if you find the right man
right at 35. yeah you get in a
relationship at 35. when are you going
to think about having a child I don't
know that can happen in six months that
can happen in two years time that's not
uh you know calendar and we don't
planify our life day by day that things
just happens and I just don't feel like
I'm less valuable than 20 years old I'm
just different so did you know one out
of three women under 30 have fertility
issues one out of everything our food is
different today so so I don't even know
if I want to tell you so like so I I
know but I'm saying for the right guy so
if you found the guy that that you would
have a kid with like that that's more of
a risk when you're older yeah it's free
to go with that 20 years old if you just
won't think about me as a baby machine
it's free to go either 20 years old girl
I'm fine I'm just conscious about my age
exactly happy yeah yeah we're talking
about baby right now so I just answer
the question you're values yeah my value
I'll explain to you I explained to you
just now that my value is not about how
many when men I slept with is not about
how many eggs I contain steel because
I'm not a baby machine my value is about
how many money I can make because I
probably can make more money than I
meant out there it's about it's about
what I can deal with life every day I
don't need a man this is my value okay I
stand by my own this is my value so the
question is can you find a man that can
stand next to me and deal with me yeah
but when you say that I still value to
him that's it who's that yeah for me I
don't I don't know
like when you're selling something she
talking about cars when you're selling
something is you you decide the value of
your entire Market the market does so so
okay that's like me saying okay I'm Envy
like an NVA y an NBA player that's like
that's like okay stop stop interrupting
me that's that's like me saying that I
can get a top one percent guy so I would
say I deserve a guy that can that can
makes half a million but none are lining
up to buy me then I'm not I'm not worth
that that's your value and so so you
can't just tell men oh I'm still just as
valuable but you just did you just went
off
I gonna repeat clearly so I know very
clearly what I want okay now as as you
said probably I'm not available so I
don't want to get what I want cool I
stay by my horn I don't need a man like
oh I get what I want I guess I can just
say buy my own I don't need a man I know
the other child I'm like a person I'm
not a baby machine I'm not uh you know
what I mean like that's my values I
stand by my own for what you're saying
you don't sound very happy about that no
I just don't I'm not very happy about
how another other women can think about
our body and our Essence
I didn't I'm telling you what men want
yeah but you can you can think in your
way and that's that's perfect
I've taught you thousands of men yeah
some men approach her and then she's
saying the value that she brings to the
man that is approaching her whether he
chooses to go to her or on once or 20
whatever obviously he's approached her
so he's like Alexa so that's the value
that she brings that's that's the point
I'm saying I've never talked about you
guys I don't know
but the question is is that fair to
expect monogamy so I'm saying over a
certain age you're less valuable to men
and then as soon as I say as soon as I
say that you guys get triggered no no
and you guys you keep you keep
interrupting this is this is this is
this is my this is she no no no I'm
saying
stops
stop this is rude this is my show it's
very rude to interrupt the host okay
like so so sorry like this is
disrespectful sorry carry on and so I'm
saying that if you're going to men and
telling them what they should value and
every time I say this is what men value
you guys you keep arguing with it then
you want to say well what what are my
best years this this this and this I get
that but I'm just saying she asked the
question and said that this girl said
she's 30 and then you said you're 30. so
when you get to 30 you made it personal
about her but I don't know why no no
sorry I don't know yeah she said once
she gets to 35 and then her eggs blah
blah blah she asked her something
personal about her so that's that's why
it got personal because you made it
about honestly so that's why she was
talking about herself and not saying
that you expect all men to accept this
value blah blah blah the point is if if
a certain man approaches her and this is
the value that she gives or she brings
and the guy doesn't want it then that's
fine I can understand that you're saying
that this is men want XYZ men want
um whatever you said from a certain age
or whatever as if to say no man
approaches a 30 or 35 year old woman
when those two 30 year old women sat
here who men approach
difference between like four set like
like it doesn't count unless you're
getting a brain none of it counts yeah
it doesn't count yeah it doesn't it
doesn't yeah you can be approached your
number can be taken your Instagram can
be got but if you're not being kept it
doesn't matter fair enough you can tell
any man I get moved to 10 times a day
cool all right do you have a man no
maybe we don't I remember because we
don't want men like the majority of the
men okay so it's not about you taking
women it's about we like each other we
find you know the match so you cannot
talk about wema as someone they've been
taken yeah but again
I learned something today yeah yeah
auntie we me and Auntie had a
conversation RT explained to me I said
are you in a relationship she said yeah
I'm in a relationship and I said does
that so does that mean you're not part
of the 35 and over leftover women which
was a topic that we were speaking about
at the time and she went I'm still part
of that category and I said I don't get
it like you're in a relationship you've
you've made it and she went no I have
I've got I haven't got a ring so I'm
still a part of that category and I
didn't get it because I was like why
you're in a committed relationship you
where you right all because I'm in a
committed relationship I'm a leftover oh
I'm a leftover in a committed
relationship yes that was it and that's
what I actually said and even when you
was talking about the value the
difference with now is that yeah at 25 I
was hot
do you know me I was hot slim hot and
that's nah you are that is fooling
myself
I look hot for somebody of 53. Germany
but act fooling myself that I look as
hot as I am at 53 as I did at 25. no I'm
just the obsession is that the same man
that I was with at 25 is the same thing
that I was with now do you know I mean
but other than that no
and I'm not fooling myself to say that
you know I mean I was lucky enough that
he had my best years and he's still got
my best years and I had his the best
years but at the end of the day I can't
turn around and say I'm better off at
anybody else at 53 because anybody else
at 53 mostly got a wedding ring on
they'd be married or something like that
by the end of the day if it weren't for
a fluke I'm just like everybody else
yeah I'm a leftover in a committed
relationship and that's what women feel
to realize that yes before you think
about oh I'm gonna be single I'm going
to be this and I'm going to be that
you've got to fix yourself you know what
because before I started thinking like
that I was like you know I've got to get
my pension I gotta get my own house I
gotta get the house done in case I'm
disabled I gotta get my will gotta get
my LPA because just in case you end up
on your own and you know something 32
years and I'm still got that mindset you
know what because I'm still left over
because I've still got to think like
that so I'm gonna affecting myself yeah
I've been with the guy for like 30
something years I got so I've got to
still think like that you know what
because I've got nothing else you're
doing the right thing because fool
myself and say I've got the same Worth
to him as I was years ago or I look you
know I mean oh yeah you're a hot time
so the goal is marriage then is that the
goal should always be marriage because
that's when you know a guy is committed
to you and that's why I said you can be
a woman for today I was talking the
other week and I was saying a man could
be with you for 30 years 40 years 50
years whatever so there's a ring on your
fingers not committed to you you can
step out so you said you've been with
the same person that you've been with
since you were 25 no before that yeah
since you were before 25 and did you
have kids or no we got two separate
children you've got two so you've not
had kids together since since you no we
haven't okay
that's interesting and I can go around
and say oh yes when I was 35 I look
really good and we could try and have
children together come on by the time
you're 35. you feed yourself yeah I
could have better kid at 35 of him but
then you've got to think to yourself how
old am I going to be when I got the kid
goes Nursery am I well I'm gonna be
winning I'm gonna go and pick up my
grandkids now I don't want to be going
picking up my child and they're saying
who's that is that your grandma no it's
my mummy and then nowadays you're
thinking about secondary school or
university I don't want to be in those
70 years old I'm going to picking up my
child and say oh yeah they're graduate
and you're playing with fire because
um the average if you want to freeze
your eggs and go that route like that it
costs like 25 000 there's no guarantee
it'll work the average person can afford
that no I'm just thinking it's
interesting because you said you were
together from before you were 21st or
what like 22 23 about that yeah 22 23
and then but you you were in the like
you guys said the best years of your
life whatever and still didn't have kids
still laughing them
sorry you're still I'm still having that
no no I'm just going by what these I'm
saying by the word by the worst from the
they said I wouldn't have a child from
35 onwards so according to a man if a
man wants to have a child and that that
would have been the time to get to have
a child then not like 30 Because by the
time 30 comes we're like forget it you
know what I mean forget it because I'm
putting my body through that and buy a
pod according what um said your name
again KB KB he said especially when a
woman has a child with the before
that's the best year also because this
has very strong a close relationship
between you know the your your baby uh
dad and yourself right so but you are
actually just showing that that's not
true so yeah because the difference you
don't know my story the difference is is
that I had an abusive relationship
that's why I've got no Hangouts so
there's a completely different if it was
a happy relationship and I had my son
and we left that'd be different by
number one I was on contraception when I
had my son so he wasn't planned and
because of that reason that's why I
decided to have one child because I will
say one is a mistake two can say is an
accident three is cared as four and
above your white list
so as far as I'm concerned I had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you add a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
valuable women so he actually spent
after the best here with you in this
scenario
no I mean this is just compromise
that what you guys saying it doesn't
happen
at the age at between like say was a
twenty between the 20th I'm agreeing if
I wasn't with him and I spent what
they're trying to say is that if I had
met him at 30 why should he be faithful
to me when I've given my best years to
some other man if I stayed with my baby
father yeah until I was 30 and then said
you know what I'm gonna get back with
the first one the one I'm with now why
should he be monogamous why should he
stay with me because you have a lot of
stuff giving up my good life my good the
best of my life when I was young free
sexy agile fling my legs over my
shoulders was all between the ages of
twenties
you don't have the youth and you don't
have the Purity at 30. it's gone so it's
you don't have what men value okay as I
said a festival right now uh 20 years
old like girl cannot have Purity anymore
because they probably lose the virginity
when they 12 but let's forget about it
so if that the point that means that
every woman that uh as child a child
before Oh yes relationship important
relationship people could not have a
husband later and I saw a lot of people
that actually ADD child before and after
they get married or whatever so what do
you mean that uh demand that actually
you know wifey air is uh I don't know
it's a bomb like or a bomb well man
don't I don't care about your job like
you could like you could do nothing and
like men do not give a [__] like because
you said earlier like I make money and
I'm like well not to men that's like a
shoe collection to women like if a guy
if a guy says if a guy says oh I have a
cool shoe shoe collection we're like oh
that's then we keep moving that's how
men feel about work okay
they'd prefer a girl that like does
nothing so she can like hang out with
them and like don't on them
good yeah I mean one person can get
married unemployed not two
yeah
honestly honestly speaking
um me myself because we're talking about
what are men expecting from a women but
we're not talking about what are we even
expecting is expecting from our men and
then we always hear it because we always
know no no did you did you in my point
oh like you think like what are we
talking about now is just a part of the
you know men in the world which is
probably the majority but doesn't mean
that is the totality guys so okay anyway
it's fine yeah we can we can keep saying
that's the majority and um I'm fine with
that cool all right but again
a man going out and saying okay cool I
want to go and find a virgin yeah and
we're gonna go and find this virgin it's
the same way you're saying in oh I'm
gonna be this exception and I will find
that guy who wants me no but you're
saying it's not your talent no no no no
no you didn't get my point I don't give
a to find The Men Who evaluate me
because I know I know about my value I
don't need that man to recognize my
value
if I gonna find him cool but if I don't
I can stand on my own I'm paying my
bills I got a job well I do what do I
need a man for okay to have sex but
that's fine I can still have sex I have
a question I have a question how do you
determine what your value is right I
told you I told you for me is an
independent woman who can stand by his
own can pay air bills he has the
maturity to understand even when is the
right time to have a children because
everyone can have a child anytime just
you know and then it's also about how we
have our you know we kind of party we
are so it's not just about having eggs
because honestly I prefer a woman that
stay without children instead someone
that who doesn't deal properly so
question who is that valuable to
what you just listed who is that
valuable to you mean who who yeah who is
that valuable to
what you just myself I don't care about
other people's opinion okay so I I need
to like that's just to people that I
should like worry about God and myself
not about other men not about no at all
no no no no what should I killed okay
okay finish your line of questions okay
so so I just want to clarify so you
don't care what men want and and the way
you determine your value is what you say
yeah isn't that a bit narcissistic no
he's not because you only care about
yourself and not what anyone else wants
no listen the point I didn't say it just
about myself just about the people that
actually is in in my small circle which
is different because when someone comes
inside my circles they actually
understand my value I don't need to
explain to them so that's the point the
other point obviously I don't I don't
give a [__] about any uh not offense but
really about people that is not in my
small circle so
like okay I'm not vulnerable okay cool
like peace like I'm gonna come back to
my life I'm gonna go to work tomorrow
I'm gonna keep paying my bills and you
know I mean like okay
so you you basically turn into that like
this is what girls do though like women
turn into the men they want to marry so
if you're looking for a guy like all the
things you I'm not looking for a guy no
no no no I know you're not I'm saying
but like typically I'm saying in general
like I don't know you personally but I'm
saying in general when women become the
men they want to marry so they become
all the things that like men want
because what she just described that's
the mat like that's a man I would date
but it's not a woman it's not what men
want yeah like a guy that's independent
that pays his bills that goes like he
gets the bag I'm like sign me up but to
a man that's like that's a red flag we
said men don't care what a woman about
her career yeah that's what I said so
then if she's making money getting her
bag whatever whatever a man wouldn't
care no no no no I don't care so then
her values so then a man will approach
her then a man will want her a man can
walk into Tesco and see an attractive
girl at the till I agree he wants to
change her life
um a woman will not walk into Tesco see
an attractive man that's what you think
I agree
it's not the totality I had I've been in
relationship with men that honestly in
less than me they add absolutely nothing
and where are they now
it what does it mean that I like what
about other other men that are six foot
and they I don't know they billionaire
they anyway go like you know if you if
you meet a billion and you're dating a
billionaire you fumble the bag
I actually I actually like comparing I
probably had more relationship with
people that you know are less Rich than
someone that I probably didn't give a
chance I didn't give a chance to them
right so it's not absolutely you've
dated like broke guys is what you're
saying I add some not broken but
I wasn't checking the impact honestly
I'm not doing it still now do you think
you attract feminine guys because you're
more masculine uh no I wouldn't say
family honestly just people with bolts
which is different it's not about yeah
it's not about being feminist about
being very confident because when you're
standing next to me because I think I'm
tough I got strong personality you need
both honestly and then someone else who
prefer a young lady who doesn't work who
can be manipulated and can be you know
controlled because you are this strong
in the relationship I need a man it
doesn't really it's a partnership like
we are together we're strong in the same
way when a man is looking for a younger
lady which is Virgin who doesn't work he
probably earn less than me is because
they need to feel like they are the
strongest one they controlling they're
controlling they taking the power in the
relationship people just deciding what
you believe men no that's my point of
view
I'm not designing I'm expressing my
point of view as you decide before you
said I'm not designing yeah you said men
go for younger women because they feel
they're going to control them and
manipulate them what if men said that
about women they look so stupid if
they're like like women like Rich guys
because they want to manipulate and
control them people be like that's a
cope you just need to go make money and
it's the same thing when women say
things like that to men like you're
shaming them the shame like this is like
the common tactics are shame guilt
insult wait Shame Shame insult guilt and
need to be right yeah no I'm not need to
that's the point guys you have like you
work like you're working like a horse
you don't see like on the left on the
right yes because I accepting your point
of view by you saying that I want to
control your own mentions
I never said that sorry I'm sorry you're
telling the room how they experienced
you no you know you're telling me if
more than one person if more than one
person in the room no you guys are
saying like how a man should I look at
me no I never said your name yeah I
don't I don't know what you do no
honestly when I say to me I'm saying to
women because I belong to the uh
actually I don't know if you guys
realize but yeah so the category of when
women know me myself you belong to women
yes and we're talking about what men
want from women you then take yourself
out of belonging to women to say what
you are no you you've been doing that no
I just I'm standing you just said I
belong to women right and the
discussions we're having is what men
want from women
you represent the totality of men in
this world do you represent the totality
of men in this world and so a girl need
to be right no I'm the statistics I
don't need to be right I don't need to
be right like
because like it's based on what like
honestly statistics all day the majority
let's say the Statics the statistics
make it right and you come out with the
best number ever okay let's let's say
that okay cool so the majority of men
think like you right all right cool I'm
accepting that you prefer at 20 years
old women I just don't give a [__] is it
clear like I don't give a [__] so you
can prefer go out with a 20 years old
girl F child married uh whatever you
want I hope you do I'm by yourself
go get that 20 year old you know I'm a
certainly right cool I just don't give a
[__] that's fine as you don't give a
[__] about what I think so why you
cannot just say okay this is just a
different point of view as I'm accepting
your point of view that's cool that's
cool for me like you're quite you're
quite angry for being cool no I'm not no
look you can just come get confused
between have energy I'm pretty energetic
I know it doesn't seem like I think you
know I just wanna like um community
trying to communicate my point which is
different I'm not angry to you or like
to anyone else just my point I want to
make it clear because I think I've been
invited for this reason that's the point
I'm not angry at all like honestly
speaking okay all right cool good good
it's passionate yeah there you go I'm
just Italian Guys
give me food and conversation I can
okay are men or women the prize
it's in the room yeah are men or women
the prize all right cool bit give me a
second oh women depressed I said women
the prize women are depressed okay wait
tell me why because they're the ones
that we're going for well me personally
I'm game for the woman and I want to go
for the women that I believe is the
right woman and someone who else many
people would want okay go ahead no I
made it the prize
um we we run Society we keep Society
going I'm not saying women
of the prize we're another prize okay
what do you think men or women who
surprised
[Applause]
let me just
so are men or women the prize in what
sense like in the world or in in the
dating game in The Dating Game
well women okay women know the prize
what do you think nasty 50 50 50. you
think like half a woman half a man okay
fair enough go ahead men no matter the
price what do you think Auntie
okay man there's more women anyway so I
can't remember the prices so many of
them running out around that day it's
gonna be men so second question are do
women date up or down
they they up okay up when they can help
you okay do women date up or down uh day
up yeah I answered for me personally up
up okay
they date down they sleep up
yo that's cold
so if women if women date up wouldn't
that make men the prize
it's a good point really
I get the point but I don't I still
don't see men as the prize
why not
so let me get this right you've
acknowledged the point
I understand I understand the point
allow me to finish so you've
acknowledged the point right but you
don't agree can you explain why no I you
asked me who are the prize and relate I
still I'm I'm still I'm an alarm about
the question about the on the question
anyway like who's the prize sort of
because then it's like the whole value
thing and all that sort of stuff so
that's why I just said women just to
give an answer that women are the prize
because of
what they bring to a relationship or
whatever it is right I just said it just
whatever but then what was it you said
again that why do women date up I said I
said do women date up or down and so if
majority of the women here said date up
yeah why would a man would be the prize
yes but then dating up you're not dating
down so so if they're dating up then the
men are dating down
because oh no but yeah but if women are
dating up
and men are dating down you're saying
that women are not the prize that a man
is the price yeah so then men would just
date men because men are the prize why
are men dating down if a man is
surprised when all men just date all
men's
this is okay okay okay okay
we're talking we're talking about
straight people okay yeah they want to
date why would men date each other when
they're straight I like this isn't you
just said men are the people would make
men the prize yeah because man could
date up but they don't they date down
yeah so then men would be the prize that
means they don't have a choice
there's some women that would be up
there are some women that would be down
there are women that would be up like
Oprah is up right so then a man has to
be above her to date down to her the
Oprah's not up no I'm just general like
I'm just saying like value money
whatever I can't think of a Young Rich
no no no that's not up though so what's
up then foreign
[Laughter]
that means he's dating up yes it depends
on her personality as well okay I
personally all of that she works
there's some guys that might want
so she would be considered high in them
so she's high value yeah in the day in
Market yes so then wait here here's my
thing yeah you're now starting to
understand how men think we we're
totally okay
yeah the clock is right so if that is a
woman that is high value yeah and then
why would that woman want to date you
wouldn't she want to date someone high
value someone up yeah yeah
right so then wait
you know what I see where you're going
with this because you're saying high
value women go for high value men yes
you're saying they're correct that
there's an equality there yeah but for
us low value man who is trying to date
up she doesn't want you okay
yeah you're absolutely yeah yeah that's
why that's why one in three men are
virgins are haven't had sex in the past
year because nobody wants them so so
you're saying men are dating down yeah
so by dating down you're saying he's
dating someone over 25 30. he's not
account is up whose eggs are cracked and
yeah I mean guys look guys he's dating
down guys will put up with more than men
do so they will put up with more and
date I'm sorry yeah the the guy will put
up with more and date down yeah because
he doesn't have a choice but he'll still
cheat on that woman he still has a right
to not be monogamous sir because her
value is low it depends but you don't
have a choice because no the high value
woman doesn't want you so you're dating
down right but a lot of high value women
die alone because
a lot of eight to tens that are very
pretty dialogue because they can't leave
the streets because they're so used to
the attention like that like what sorry
go ahead then you still use the
attention
um this is like honestly I've just heard
this from guys this is just like
strictly this is just
experience that I've had like talking to
guys the last like two years yeah and
they just say a lot of girls that are
like very pretty and they're given like
like that's the most valuable thing you
can be given is Extreme Beauty like you
come out you can get a modeling contract
and girls waste it and they waste their
best years that doesn't make you high
value just because you're right you're
right sorry sorry technically if we're
gonna go high value woman the man I
misused the term like a high value woman
technically has to be chosen by a high
value manner I just met like like very
attractive women that are like the most
sought after they wouldn't be you're
right I use the rest
yes and I'm saying like a lot of like
the most beautiful women die alone
because they're they're so used to being
like an eight to ten and that's their
whole personality they can't they break
they've never been bullied like like if
you tell a girl she's not special they
freak out most people aren't small well
go ahead that would make you low value
if you're if you're beautiful but you
don't have any other qualities you're
still in the streets you're still a
whole you're low value yeah the
equivalent would be a [__] I don't
know a cryptocurrency but well you're
not you're not low value if you're
dating game if you're if you're
beautiful you like oh like someone
that's 300 pounds isn't going to get in
the same like she could have a nobody
count you're gonna get the initial
attention yeah but if you have nothing
else in your home yeah like you hear
your background you've just been ran
through correct correct yourself but
that's that's why I say like girls that
are eight to tens often die alone that's
that's what I was saying because because
they're so used to that attention that
they it's like a drug they can't they
can't they can't so wait wait wait this
is just this is just what I've heard
from men okay so like I'm not sure but
it depends on no but honestly it depends
on your culture your background like
sorry the last if you look at we can go
to like Instagram chicks yeah
the majority of them are single your
Bernice all of them and they may get
gifts they may get dated but are they
kept how many of them do you see that
are kept this is the point that you're
referring to looks only but that's what
that's what we're saying eight to tens
yeah but that's that's low value so wow
no no no so what she's saying is when
you start with looks like we as much as
people want to pretend that you know
this personality stuff matters the
initial attraction is looks yeah so when
you are attractive and you have pretty
privilege yeah you're gonna get
attention so what she's saying is when
you get that sort of attention it's like
a drug you go out and you know that
you're gonna have The Pick of men coming
to attract and move to and talk to you
and sell you drinks exactly right but
you're still not being kept at the end
of the day no one is going to turn that
attraction and those dreams into
marriage in to a ring and they die alone
right I understand that but you could
you could say the same for some men but
like a dude can be 50 and a girl that's
30 will still find him fine but like
it's not the same vice versa you could
be 50 and a [__] and you're not
attractive guy yeah you could be a guy
you have all the money in the world but
you just know well mostly don't turn
women on correct most men have died a
lot like you know I think we're only 40
only only 40 only 40 of men have
reproduced throughout history
so where 80 of women have so the
majority of men do die alone you're
right it's just a new thing for women
because like they they get because they
don't listen to what men want anymore
so how do we fix that it's coming from
how do we like level the playing field
there we're doing it slowly well I mean
to me it's like the it's the you you get
rid of the consequence more people do it
so if you pay women to leave marriages
the more girls are going to do it
they're paid through child support and
through the government
like when you pay women to make bad
decisions every bad decision we make
we're bailed out of you could be
homeless there's a women's shelter to
take care of you you could sleep around
you can get an abortion to bail you out
like whatever bad decision women make
there's a bailout there's incentives
yeah like like so if you're paid to make
bad decisions more women make bad
decisions like they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop till the
consequence goes away yeah you know that
was a big thing in the country
what'd you say earlier sorry there's uh
she didn't know she didn't hear it and I
said in my day you know women were just
kind of they're getting pregnant
together yeah yeah yeah he's a
first-time pilot heard of it and I said
yeah
hit reality hard because if a man makes
a bad decision or if he ain't [__] the
world will tell him yeah well they will
feed women lies and let her live in
delusion like even even when I said
you're less valuable when you hit 30
like that shouldn't be that's just life
yeah like I'm less valuable than I was
when I was 22. it just is what it is it
is what it is it's not it's not a
personal attack on me yeah we're not
talking about personal worth but
honestly honestly honestly to everyone
like your looks are currency girls don't
even like we don't know how good they
have it because you are given more
attention and opportunity because of the
way you look life is on easy mode as a
young pretty girl [__] like hit 50 let
life change ever
but you you're
like you hate my age you best learn to
cook
we see it every day in the world but
people still choose to argue the fact it
is true as a 21 year old your life was
different to how it is now it is a fact
it is a fact when you were younger you
were more attractive you went out you
you felt fresher